good to be here so we're focused on
machine learning all right we'll we'll
take a data approach but this is a
machine learning thing so our goal is to
improve a machine learning model the
goal is to have a machine learning model
that works in the real world on real
data and that's the focus and how do we
do that with the current situation in
terms of architectures and what's out
there in terms of data we're focused on
automatically finding and fixing data
and label issues
so this the idea is systematic automated
ways to do this not human driven
I spent a lot of time on this about 10
years and I'm I say this because I just
like you guys I care about my time so a
lot of this the first half of this is
going to be focused on why would I do
that why does this seem to be really
important I built the cheating detection
system at MIT in Harvard and a big issue
we Face there is with false negatives
and false positives how do you know for
sure that someone didn't cheat
how do you know someone didn't commit a
crime how do you guys know I'm not lying
right now it's very difficult so we
assume in a sense until proven guilty
and so it's very difficult machine
learning task because you have a lot of
labels that are zero but they might
actually be one and it turned out at the
time that machine learning did not work
for this task there was no machine
learning algorithm that was
generalizable for multi-class standard
classification that worked with noisy
labels I found that shocking the machine
learning doesn't work on real world data
I thought that was really wild so I
spent my whole PhD trying to solve that
problem this is solving not solved but
we've made a lot of Headway uh quite a
bit we'll focus on some of that so this
is focused on lessons and I'll go
through six lessons the first five are
sort of motivational six one is how do
we solve it the first lesson is that the
best model is only as good as the data
it learns from
um so I don't know if you guys have seen
this article but says when algorithms
mess up the nearest human gets the blame
and I'd like to try to reframe this and
think about this paper that many of us
have seen which basically says garbage
in garbage out if you train a machine
learning model on data with completely
random labels it will produce
predictions that are completely random
it's a great model it works perfectly it
can be hyper parameter optimized we can
use all the greatest and latest and
you'll get a model that gives you
complete garbage because it's trained on
garbage data and so I just like to
reframe this and say instead of when
algorithms messed up what if instead we
said when algorithms are trained on
erroneous data and so it's a different
way of thinking about the problem
um the second lesson is that data and
label issues are plaguing some of the
most used AI Tech right now that's
really hot so we'll look at a few
examples uh that you guys will be very
familiar with openai has openly stated
that some of the biggest issues with
Dolly and gpt3 are label issues and data
issues so we'll get a few quick examples
this is from their tutorial video on
Dolly too show of hands who knows Dolly
image generation okay sweet yeah so you
can just check this video out for
yourself but pretty much like the main
issue that they talk about throughout
the video is that it will randomly
Generate random images because it was
trained on data that was different
labels you had an avocado and it was
labeled cucumber and then you say give
me an image of like you know a cucumber
and it gives you an avocado and this
actually happens quite a bit it's just
bad bad labels but how do you look at
millions of data and find all these
labels and train on good data
another example so this is just more
examples from that another example is uh
chat GPT many people know this already
but the whole idea was to take gpt3
and then the biggest issue was that
there was a lot of like untruthful and
biased and harmful data so they had
humans actually go through label the
quality for each and then retrain it on
high quality data so the biggest issue
with gpt3 was really on the data side
not the machine learning algorithm there
weren't that many Innovations on the
machine learning side it was really how
do we actually automate this process and
at the time they're using humans to
actually check and label things and give
quality scores but how do we automate
this process of taking data that's bad
and biased and has problematic outputs
and then train a model in a smarter way
on better data so it's the same idea
repeating over and over we're seeing
this across the industry in the most
pervasive Technologies every major tech
company struggles with this problem so
just personally I have done an
internship or contingent research
position or some kind of some kind of
position at meta at Oculus research at
Google at Amazon at Microsoft and same
problem over and over that's what I
worked on in all five places this is
pervasive across the industry if you
guys have seen this article andrewing
basically saying that uh you know 80
percent of like the time spent and the
Machine learning pipeline is actually
just improving data quality and then
there's lots of Articles talking about
how much this costs the US and the
economy but that it should be solvable
um have you guys seen this by Andrew by
Andre carpathy
this is Tesla's data engine this is how
they train their machine learning models
for self-driving cars and really what it
comes down to is they have you know
their their car driving and then they do
it in an area that they don't have a lot
of data on so this is a tunnel it's very
dark they don't have a lot of data in
that dark tunnel so you're driving in
the tunnel and the car starts doing
weird things and so what do they do well
they have to get that data and then
generate a bunch more by collecting more
data of that type and then they have to
label it and then train it and do this
repeatedly so imagine if instead you
could actually go through your data set
and know hey this is all my low quality
data this is all the stuff that my
model's not going to do well I can
augment this ahead of time instead of
deploying the car having it crash and
wreck a bunch in tunnels and then
repeating this process so that's what
you'd like to automate you'd like tools
to try to automate this this is a really
great uh image and I think a good way to
think about this is Imagine like Elon
Musk comes to you and he says all right
Andre I need you to get this car to just
work for stop lights and you think okay
that seems pretty easy like green light
go red light stop and then you go out in
the real world and data is like totally
crazy right like these this is stop
lights all over the world and so the
reality here is that data equality is
very complicated and data is not always
what it seems sometimes labels are not
as simple as green light red light and
so what do you do how do you handle the
situation and in this case these would
be identified as outliers and there are
automatic solutions to do that and they
can be identified as low quality labels
and hard data and there are lots of ways
that we can solve that in automated ways
this is a great slide that just that
Andre shared in the same talk where he
says all right this is the amount of
time I spent my PhD and this is the
amount of time at Tesla in terms of data
sets and machine learning models and so
you see this transformation as you go
into deploying these things in the real
world of how much time gets spent on the
data versus the machine learning model
and there's a bunch more examples you
can check out you can check the slides
out later so the fourth lesson is that
and this might be a surprise I'm
actually curious how many people know of
this result
sweet
cool yeah it's pretty wild if you look
at the top 10 machine learning data sets
that this is the test sets that we've
been benchmarking on as a field
okay so this is like what the test sets
we've benchmarking all our algorithms on
you know from like the top institutions
in the world that are doing machine
learning research and it turns out that
all 10 of them have errors uh like
sometimes pervasive errors we looked at
the Google data set which is Google
Quick Draw and it had at least 10 label
errors so you're benchmarking on these
things you're saying this is the best
model on this data set but that data set
totally has uh wrong data in it and so
how can you trust those benchmarks these
are just a few examples from five of
those data sets uh the Google Quick Draw
one is on the right mnist from yamukun
on the left cfar Caltech imagenet these
are all labelers they're just in those
data sets just bad data and previously
there was no way to really find these
things automatically and so we started
focusing on that problem seeing how we
can solve that to improve machine
learning models at scale and in
production and this is a table where you
can see all of those tabulated across
the tin there's a website here if you
want to check them out I won't go
through it it's a lightning talk so
we're going lightning speed but you can
check that out labelers.com and there
there's 10 different data sets there
including audio image and text
um fifth lesson your test benchmarks uh
might not reflect real world performance
so let's look at a quick graph on the
left you see a model that has 100 test
accuracy but actually there's some bad
data mixed in there so here the inside
is the true label on the outside or the
inside is the observed label and the
outside is the true label and so it
turns out that actually this model that
looks like it has 100 test accuracy say
it was a car and you put it out in the
real world and there's a cliff and
there's not a cliff and this is like the
probability it goes over the cliff then
like in the real world it's going over
the cliff a third of the time it's going
to be very costly and so it's really
important that your test data sets have
accurate labels or you can't trust your
benchmarks
um so the sixth is how do we focus on
solving these problems and so I'll chat
a bit about what we're doing and sort of
the underlying mechanisms and the
research behind it
um some of the initial algorithms and
research that was done in order to solve
this problem that was in productionized
is called confident learning
um it was initially inspired by things
from information Theory and Quantum
Computing uh the key idea is that you
want to have a theoretically grounded
solution like if you're going to say
this is label errors can we actually
prove at least for certain data sets
that we can exactly find labelers and
can we say for other data sets that we
have some confidence that will do a good
job and so there's a lot of theory
behind this the inspiration from Quantum
Computing if you guys are familiar with
NMR Quantum Computing I don't know it's
like getting more esoteric for this
conference but my PC advisor he built
the first quantum computer Isaac chuang
um cool guy I worked with him for like
eight years and I was inspired by him a
lot of the key solutions for Quantum
Computing where you have a quantum
computer you do a bunch of emulations
and what you get to measure is a noisy
signal and so you end up with a data set
that's like a bunch of uh sort of states
of the quantum computer but there's a
bunch of errors in there and so what you
do is you actually estimate what was the
noisy channel that got you what you
observed and then you can reverse
engineer that noisy channel it's just a
matrix of flipping rates to figure out
what the original computation was on the
computer and then you can actually
estimate the computation that's
happening on the on the quantum computer
so that's how that works and I thought
hey we can do the same thing with any
arbitrary data set that's just a data
set so it should work for images it
should work anything that you can
represent as numerical data with labels
it should work and we applied that we
spent a lot of time on that about half a
decade and we were able to pull this off
and so that's kind of how clean lab got
started and that's the underlying
mechanism uh behind it and so there's a
paper you can check it out there's a
bunch of papers on this now but what's
neat about this is that it works with
any model any data set and any modality
so it's not specific to like images or
text the goal is to solve this problem
for any sort of data set
um there's a bunch of stuff on this this
is not just for random labelers the idea
is like a dog is much more likely to get
mislabeled as a fox than as a bathtub
and so what you want is something that
works for systematic issues like
systematic errors in data like with the
real world and so this is a solution
that works for that I'm going to skip
the math notation I've kept it in the
slides for those who are interested and
who want to look at this later but it's
it's a quick talk at the end you get an
estimate so this is something you want
to estimate this is basically the joint
probability of any two sort of mistakes
co-occurring so on the left you see for
example like a noisy label Fox and then
on the top left you see true label dog
so this would mean that if you had like
100 examples that 14 are labeled Fox but
should be labeled dog and this is the
thing that you estimate using confident
learning and then we build a lot of
algorithms on top of that
um this is a really quick demo that
shows uh this equation is like let's
look at the probability of an example if
it's greater than some threshold for
each class then we can say hey it's
probably labeled that thing so you can
go through a data set and this is
showing a simulation which and a
lightning speed talk you can only go so
far but I just want to show you that you
can filter out a data set into that
Matrix I mentioned and what ends up
happening is that the things on the
diagonal are the things labeled
correctly and the things on the off
diagonal are your label errors and you
can then get actually a confidence and
guarantees about this for certain data
sets with certain assumptions and then
with others you will relax those
assumptions with other data sets and you
can check that out uh after so these are
for example the two label issues that
are detected using this method
um I don't know how much you guys into
this math stuff I don't know I don't
know if I've Got the Right audience
yeah maybe I'll leave this one for later
this is a quick proof that just shows
for an arbitrary machine learning model
like ones that you guys are using every
day they don't produce perfect predicted
probabilities so you can show that these
uh the algorithms that we build on work
perfectly for perfect predictive
probabilities but most models are not
perfect and so what happens is like what
how does this stuff work when you have
for example like a miscalibrated model
or a model that's producing erroneous
predicted probabilities or a model
that's spitting out like say it's always
really confident in dogs it's seeing
lots of dogs so the probabilities for
dogs are like a little bit high and this
will show you that you get exactly the
same result you can still guarantee
perfect label error finding I'll let you
check that out later it's really simple
argument
um okay so this is a table showing a
bunch of methods like this is the one
out of Google this is the one out of
Facebook
um and then it can just show how these
methods outperform those a key thing
about this table is that on the right is
much more realistic that means most the
0.6 means that most of that Matrix is
like 60 of it is zeros that means most
of the flipping and like errors is only
in a few classes that's very realistic
and much harder that's what the real
world's like and so what we show is that
using these methods you get the same
Improvement in your model regardless of
how realistic so in the most realistic
scenario you still get the same
Improvement whereas you see a massive
drop off in uh most of the sort of
primary attack Solutions
um cool so uh just a quick few things if
you guys like open source there's a
bunch of stuff in the cleanlab package
you can check out and most of it's like
one line of code so everything I just
showed you can be found uh can be run
um in some production
um and you can check this out find label
issues is way to find label issues you
can also find outliers you can also find
the best consensus label if you have a
bunch of annotators and these are all
sort of one line of code algorithms
that's what we go for or like a few
lines of code
and what's neat about this is it works
for any data set many data formats any
data modalities is a very general
solution there's a big gap between sort
of having your data and it being lower
quality than you want and then the
deployed train model that works in
production and so the whole thing that
we're focused on is how do you take that
low quality data and get to a high
quality model and that's what we do and
so that's what our whole company is
about and building an Enterprise
solution that gets you from A to B
um so what's neat and different about us
we came out of MIT spent uh quite a
while on this at MIT and then three phds
founded the company and we publish
research which is pretty different than
most startups we had five papers in ICM
nerves last year
um we publish research blogs and we do a
lot of Open Source so there's two things
you can check out on your own and
appreciate your time
foreign
[Music]